what is this new personality you're
adopting you what's going on here
where's the camera i have to be like
what's up what's up man
last time i was on here i was a little
shy i'm going to show you nothing but
confidence
now i actually know what i'm talking
about because i've seen batman movies
before what did you think about this
movie
i really liked seeing batman in the
daytime that was very fun and seeing him
in water was also really cool
what did you think about the movie
cool the movie was cool i loved robert
pattinson as batman it was interesting
seeing his chemistry with
um jeffrey wright zoe kravitz
it was fun seeing him shooting yawn in
the middle of you talking i'm so sick
this wasn't the snyder cut but it was
all so long
so some of these were just like facts
about the movie they just said batman
was in the water
the advantage of a car
and i kind of like the movie
fun movie really it was really pretty
like looking visually great shots love
the use of colors
okay just
yeah i need i need the banter bro you're
doing great yeah yeah my person is my
favorite thing tonight
what's going on there reject nation we
are at cinemark today because i can't
imagine watching this movie any other
way than in the freaking movie theaters
got a private watch party here's how
much a private watch party is you give
up to 30 people for this thing and i
literally got like 29 people in the
theater right now all of them are fans
of batman so i was like look when this
movie's done i want to get some genuine
fan reactions afterwards about half of
them agreed to be on camera cinemark
rocks right john nod the camera
yeah
we like it here now we got michael tesla
with us i call him josh gad that's just
what i call
spot tonight you guys know you've heard
it before
you can't go to airports or anywhere
sum up how do you feel about this movie
it was the batman film that i didn't
know i needed and i didn't ask for uh
but that being said while i feel really
depressed uh after watching it it was
actually a really amazing film kind of
surprised the heck out of me it was nice
to have like a really raw murderous kind
of mystery robert penson he was amazing
i think he did a great job as like a
young angsty batman and i think
commissioner gordon was just
actually lieutenant gordon in this movie
lieutenant you sound like a [ __ ]
idiot michael you know go you're done i
hope you enjoyed cinemark today all
right guys this is callie um she's my
best friend i've known her for ages cali
how are you today it's great meeting you
today it's great meeting you today too i
don't know anything about you at all
what did you think about this movie
i really liked it um it was cool to see
batman kind of not have it all figured
out because like none of this stuff
would have happened in christian bales
gotham the transition of robert
pattinson from my like sparkly teenage
dream to this like kind of burly
mysterious like zaddy type role i really
really enjoyed that you described what
most people say about me so that's
really cool to hear actually i noticed
mark hansen's like really white in this
movie which actually kind of works for
the batman i saw like several people
just nod their heads like he's really
white
i know you got to get out of here but
thank you for coming and i hope you like
the time it's cinemark say something
nice about cinemark i love cinemark
sellouts all right guys we got matt
reeves with us today kyle
kyle i know that was that wasn't my joke
brother who john said that i just said
it and you got shirt at them we got uh
kyle with us
who got a lot of crap in our spider-man
video that's right i just can't imagine
running right now
what did you think about the batman very
passionate marvel fan here uh never been
into dc this is probably my all-time
favorite superhero movie period wow what
a statement you're not thinking you're
being too reactionary right now no no no
no it's honestly this actually seemed
really calm about the whole thing so i
believe
this is the first time i feel like a
character from the comics has hit their
potential the way that they should have
all along like no marvel characters ever
done this no dc character outside of
this has ever done this everything i've
wanted from this character since i was a
little kid you realize that you got crap
for not being all that into spider-man
no way home now you're gonna get crap
for saying this is the best movie ever
yeah it is nearly perfect i believe that
you believe that
it was
all right goodbye matt hey stefan hey
how's it going now a few months ago
when we were at kyle's birthday
i remember like catching up with you and
we were like dude i think this batman
movie we were like this could be it the
closest thing to like rival the dark
knight i'm not gonna have you just
compare it just because that would be
[ __ ] up but uh
what did you think about the batman be
honest okay well like you said i went
into this kind of expecting this to be
my favorite batman movie the riddler is
my favorite batman villain so it had
everything going for it and it managed
to over deliver on that for me
i
fully loved everything they did in this
movie especially with the riddler
turning him into basically like a horror
villain and he's like kind of like
jigsaw zodiac the whole time so i had
such a blast with that kind of just the
darkness of the whole thing you can kind
of see that in matt reeve's direction it
really felt like the batman movie i've
always wanted
everyone here is a bunch of pretentious
shills
no one really feels this way about the
batman
i'm genuinely i loved this one i could
see everything i wanted like i couldn't
believe what i just watched you know
there's only so far i can pull the mic
and you just keep getting further and
further you're getting closer and i'm
just like you're in my space but i'm
just like you get comfortable here we
have to be on camera again all right
olivia one of the first things that we
ever bonded over was your love for
comics specifically batman you know
she's more honest than i've ever been in
my entire life about anything everyone
should know that yeah i think this is an
incredible journey visceral raw that we
go on with
yeah all right sorry sorry i couldn't
talk for a second
i'm going to suffer the consequences of
that interruption
it's an incredible journey that we know
let's wrap this up i think this is the
best comic book movie i've ever seen
it's not meant to be a superhero film so
don't go in with that mindset this is a
comic book movie and it's incredible
would you say he's your favorite batman
yes
i think did i put too much pressure on
you right there no i'm just trying to
compare in my head all the batman do you
want me just blurt out and i have to
compare quickly yeah i want you to go to
the bathroom because i can tell you
gotta go to the bathroom all right i
love you i'll see you later
all right so greg asked me to do this in
60 and 90 seconds i'll do my best i said
30 to 60 but okay you get 98. i think
this film really nailed for the first
time ever i mean we got glimpse of it
and you know the christian bale uh films
and some of the other uh batman
iterations of what it truly means for
batman to be the detective and i really
felt like this film really nailed that i
mean this film is just non-stop
detective work i gotta say this movie
the cinematography in this film is just
unbelievable some of the aerial shots
and the the car chases the hand-to-hand
combat scenes
really quick it's great to behold on a
cinemark screen isn't it all those shots
for sure definitely you gotta see it at
a cinemark screen by the way if you go
into this film expecting an all-out
action-packed batman film in my opinion
you're going to be a little bit
disappointed if you go in going in with
like more of a character study you know
of batman i think you're going to
appreciate it a lot more because that's
what i really appreciated about this
film and what matt reeves uh did here is
it's just it's a real character study of
batman and and you know of gotham and
and some of these criminals that we get
and am i going to your time is up cue
that oscar music all right guys i met
our shot for the first time a few weeks
ago and we became really really like we
just bonded i don't wanna say really
close we bought it a lot no we're really
close now we're pretty close i'll take
it i just felt a little self-conscious
say at the time what did you think about
the batman i loved it i just thought it
was stunning like that it was a noir
right when it started i was like oh [ __ ]
this is what we're doing i like that
batman could get hurt zoe kravitz
stunning every time she was on screen
you're just like oh [ __ ] this woman is
beautiful they both looked hot they both
look great together that's what i really
liked about it the music was great the
entire score just added to the whole
thing i thought this was the closest to
the batman animated series in terms of
tone and i really liked that i felt like
i was actually watching that come to
life gotham was like really dark and
really gritty okay i'm done cool done
follow our shot on social media he has
some shirtless photos all right aaron so
i watched all the batman movies leading
into this one this is hands down the
most authentic gotham we've ever seen
this is the best performance by a batman
the most nuanced performance from a
batman we've seen to date robert
pattinson has so many layers to his
performance and the world and the noir
detective aspect of this film was unlike
any other film we've seen before and
quite frankly lives up to the potential
of what matt reeves said in making a
noir detective film
i okay did you write that down like you
said that so confidently like you went
all deep voice and you looked right in
the camera you just said it all right
did you write that down and like i'm
going to have this [ __ ] so ready to go
by the time i get on at a time limit so
i said i was going to [ __ ] do it you
nailed that i have a couple small issues
with the film but it doesn't detract at
the quality of it the cinematography is
beautiful the
uh the
music is beautiful i'm finished
get it out of the way i don't think
the way that they used uh the batmobile
felt authentic
that is my one criticism also the
riddler was uh both amazing creepy and
hilarious there's no bouncing back
literally everyone's removed back here
everyone back here just went what's he
saying here wait a minute wait a minute
i'm not done because i sell more to say
about this movie this movie is the most
batman we've ever seen batman and it's
not about him being bruce wayne it's
about him learning to become bruce wayne
he is batman and we slowly go through
his journey of becoming more like bruce
wayne the most
you guys were already sure what is
and if you guys didn't mention it you
can't just come back up here let you
know colin farrell was really good that
was also really good you're gonna do
what you did last time what did i do
last time
it just helped me
johnny connor just came up here and said
you're gonna do what you did last time
and there's no other way around
all right connie what'd you think
honestly what'd you want to do i'm going
to ask you what you thought of the film
okay you're just going to say exactly
that connie what did you think of the
film i loved it
wow
this one could be on camera connie
i really loved his car what is like the
common names that dumb americans [ __ ]
say all the time they just mispronounce
it for some reason when they read it
spelled a-l-m-a-s and they pronounce it
with like an i-a-l-m-i-s so they'll say
all miss even elementary school they
would look at it and say ole miss
weird
well i hope all those dumb asses are
watching now when i invited our shot to
come here he was like bringing my sister
boom i was like okay she must want to
see this movie or he has to do something
nice true because he messed something up
oh you're like a big bad man i'm an
actually batman fan okay so what did you
think about this movie i loved it i
didn't watch any of the trailers because
i just people do that because sometimes
the trailers give so much away and i
just wanted to go in and not know
anything and just really enjoy it and be
excited you know without like having any
expectations let's talk about uh zoe
kravitz because she is just so hot she
looked great and i really loved her as
catwoman yeah yeah and she moved great i
loved some of the action and she just
looked so stunning well it was great
getting to know you
this is our way of catching up john
after so many years it's all going to
happen on camera today it's your fault
you showed up late what you showed up
later than everyone else i was like five
minutes later you didn't even really
talk to anyone
true sure this i'm not even ask your
opinion i'm just gonna just stand here
and ridicule you for not being as early
as everyone else today do you like this
movie i'm going to keep it super simple
for you i actually enjoyed it thoroughly
i had mid expectations would love to see
it again only had mid expectations
you're the first i've ever heard say
that yeah because i think if i over blow
my expectations in comparison to like
the nolan trilogy i would be really
scared to to get my expectations not met
so that's what i was worried about how
did it measure up for you in terms of
like the nolan trilogy is it
be honest man if you don't like it have
some balls and say something for a
change sean
[Laughter]
it's hard to compare because i think
they're totally different movies are you
still processing the movie yes
definitely because a lot
i think that was the one thing is the
the time the amount of time that we're
spending is good but it did feel a
little long but i don't think it was too
much of a big gripe what was your
favorite thing about it greg frazier's
cinematography for sure it looks
beautiful um
yeah he did dune so um and a lot of
didn't even villanuev movie so i'm like
i was looking forward to how it looked
for sure yeah you were prepping imdb
facts so you can try to come on the real
rejects
to impress you absolutely 100 i don't
even know who these people are
i don't know about the score i'm kind i
i thought like i honestly i thought
trent rezner should have scored it
david fincher's movies so and this looks
like a david fincher movie absolutely
exactly exactly nothing really bad about
it other than maybe the the runtime me
do you want to breakdance
do i have to
i won't humiliate you
and i just wait do you want to break it
we got chris here now chris i know i was
really looking forward to this movie
this is our honest reactions so chris
what did you think about this
it was interesting to see him struggle
his way through everything typically you
see playboy batman or playboy bruce
wayne and he has his everything figured
out it's really intelligent this one he
uh he was a little sloppy as as batman
trying to figure everything out some
people really love it some people are
gonna not like it
the question is what did you think about
the batman what did i uh
it was good it was just it wasn't what i
expected i'll say that but i did stay
away from trailers you said it wasn't
what you expected how did you expect
something if you didn't see anything for
what to expect for it i expected the
typical batman typical bruce wayne
playboy i also didn't expect uh
it was dark you know
you seemed overwhelmed by how dark it
was it was dark i didn't expect it like
it was like whoa even the character the
riddler the riddler is always laughing
fun he's having fun as he's doing all
these terrible things and that just
wasn't the case here
well i appreciate your honesty when
you're surrounded by people who have
nothing but overwhelming praise you had
the balls to come up here and say you
know what i thought it was just all
right that takes a lot of courage yeah
you guys aren't going to do anything to
me on the way outside
you never know man guys this is taymor
i've talked to taymor maybe three times
in my life i know we share a big
passionate agreement for the snyder
verse
but what do you think about the batman
okay i'm going to be perfectly honest i
don't think i've enjoyed a batman movie
this much since the tim burton era i
know not a popular opinion but i just
[ __ ] love like burton's visual
aesthetic and i just felt like no other
directors really captured that and i
feel like this is probably the closest
we've gotten to that i appreciate that
even though it is it is grounded i think
matt reeves drew influence from like so
many things because i think there was
hints of burden there were hints of like
the batman arkham games the first one to
mention the damn games and so much of
the time i think of the games during the
first one right there's certain shots
that's like straight up out of arkham
knight like no one's like noticing this
brandon do you want to be in here 30
seconds here's the only other person
i've known as long as john maybe not as
much of a cinephile but a big batman fan
i know this yep it's true now brandon
despite how many
ridiculous bathroom breaks you took
during this movie
yeah you didn't miss any important stuff
i was always
like
what did you think about this movie i
thought it was amazing i thought it was
so cool it definitely was very
batman-ish right i think the one
the other one the big batman series that
happened big batman fan over yeah that
one was cool but this one was definitely
darker it kind of felt like the 90s
cartoon to me it's a common rhetoric
i've heard tonight okay yeah
yeah so you're just stealing opinions
down there
i waited till the end you know that bike
was a nice little tiny
nice little tiny reveal there that was
cool
[Laughter]
yeah all right cool thanks brandon
all right guys well there you have it
looks like
most people liked it
i would say most people love this movie
and uh thank you guys thank you cinemark
again for this catch you guys soon